I didn't even get a chance to talk about
this yesterday but it's absolutely
baffling and disgusting at his rally on
Saturday night Donald Trump came out
violently against the first amendment to
the Constitution of the United States
Donald Trump said in Tulsa on Saturday
night that by the way stop emailing me
saying it's I know it's Tulsa yeah come
on we're just having a good time
Trump said on Saturday night that he
wants flag-burning to be punishable by a
year in prison despite the fact that the
Supreme Court has said multiple times
flag burning is a protected activity
you can't punish people for burning a
flag it's a type of speech check it out
check out Donald Trump's audience
cheering for this supposed
constitutional conservatives cheering
for the attempted destruction of the
First Amendment by their Dear Leader who
they will of course unquestioningly vote
for in November take a look two days ago
leftist radicals in Portland Oregon
ripped down a statue of George
Washington
and wrapped it in an American flag and
set the American flag on fire Democrat
them all Democrat everything I tell you
is Democrat and you know we ought to do
something mister senators we have two
great senators we ought to come up with
legislation that if you burned the
American flag you go to jail for one
year one year the crowd not even
hesitating I mean so again so-called
conservatives who support the
Constitution cheering for Trump
suggesting we punish a constitutionally
protected activity with a year in prison
now it's also important that this I want
to focus on the the flag burning but
there's also a deliberate conflation
that Trump does Trump starts by talking
about tearing down a statue but then he
says burning the flag should be
punishable by a year in prison tearing
down a statue can be a property crime
right that's it that's a very different
thing than constitutionally protected
speech burning a flag stomping on a flag
that is not only not a crime it's
specifically protected activity it's a
form of speech protected by the First
Amendment and this is not an obscure
legal decision like this is wide legal
precedent widely known legal precedent
the Supreme Court decided in 1989 in
Texas v Johnson and it reaffirmed it in
1990 in US v eichman
or Eichmann that any prohibitions on
so-called desecration of flags are
unconstitutional it's just flat-out
unconstitutional burning a flag as a
form of speech it's symbolic speech
burning American flags is a form of
speech in protest movements that go back
a long time so what Trump is asking for
and what is audience is ravenously
cheering for it is unconstitutional will
his followers care that Trump is
proposing something unconstitutional no
mostly they won't you've got actual
principled constitutional conservatives
now when I say principled I don't mean I
agree with their views but what I mean
is
they don't abandon their principles when
Trump says the opposite and then cheer
it the way people in the crowd are doing
they are sometimes coming out like
George Will has come out and said he's
got to go trump's gotta go I don't
really agree with George Will on on most
things but George will at least abides
by the principles he has identified as
being important to him and that includes
that what's in the Constitution at least
as he sees it matters now it's important
I think to mention there are limitations
on flag-burning like you can't go on to
a neighbor's property and drop a burning
flag on their wooden porch right but
that's not the flag burning that's
illegal there it's the trespassing and
the arson whether you drop you know
papers or a burning flat if anything if
you do that there are other crimes you
are committing but that's not what we're
talking about here we're talking about
just the burning of a flag Trump kept
going calling for exactly the type of
legislation that the Supreme Court has
already said multiple times is
unconstitutional take a look
we should have legislation that if
somebody wants to burn the American flag
and stomp on it but just burn it they go
to jail for one year okay
this is what I call dumb red meat we
talk about red meat and dog whistles in
in American politics and and Republicans
very often throw them out
this is dumb red meat and Trump has
actually been using this dumb red meat
for a long time here's just one video of
Trump from 2016 you'll notice by the way
sounding far more articulate saying
something similar about flag-burning
see people ripping up the American flag
like that flag beautiful when I see I
think it's a disgrace okay and you can
say what you want free speech it's all
wonderful everything's wonderful I'm a
big believer in free speech but maybe
we're gonna be putting something in to
see if we can do something about it
because this is a special case and when
I see people burning the American flag
and then stepping on it as it's burning
up and then stomping on it and stepping
on it on the ground I don't think I
don't think in the I don't think I
remember that when I was going to set
right how many of you guys are young
like me remember when we were very young
I don't remember that happening yeah so
dumb red meat it fires people up but it
also sort of confuses them since they
thought they were for free speech and
that they were for the Constitution I
guess they thought Trump was also for
those things and then Trump comes out
with a year in prison for burning the
flag so understand I guess the takeaway
is first of all this didn't get nearly
enough attention this is the president
saying cancel the First Amendment at
least the part of it that he doesn't
like but understand how backwards things
are that we have a White House that
dropped the ball on coronavirus Trump
admitted he wanted to reduce testing
early on so that he would look better
we have protests against vile police
brutality we have nearly 20 percent real
unemployment rate and the controversies
that Trump wants to focus on are do
people kneel during the anthem or not
and did somebody burn a flag it's not
just transparent it's actually pathetic
because as I said yesterday he has no
case he has no coherent case for why he
should be re-elected and so he's talking
about flag burning and kneeling during
protests kneeling during kneeling during
the national anthem in sports as well he
it's fully authoritarian it's also
really dumb and hopefully this country
is never in a place where flag-burning
seriously has a chance at becoming
criminalized even under the relatively
conservative Supreme Court that we have
right now I don't see any way that
there's any shot at flag-burning being
criminalized as it should be let me know
your thoughts I am on Twitter at D
Pakman remember that you can subscribe
free to the daily david pakman show
audio podcast it's the earliest if you
look at all the things we publish
Facebook clips YouTube clips etc the
earliest thing to publish is the daily
audio podcast which is available for
free on iTunes stitcher google play
pandora iheartradio Spreaker pod being
spotify as you can tell it's too
available at this point really if you
love feeding your intellectual curiosity
but you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blink it's blink
Isleta consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video